[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL SAXMAN: Hello and welcome
to this week's episode of
Google Maps garage.
I'm Paul Saxman and with me this
week is Brendan Kenny.
BRENDAN KENNY: Hi.
PAUL SAXMAN: Mr. Google Maps,
JavaScript extraordinaire.
So this week we're going to talk
about actually using the
Chrome dev tools to actually
accelerate Google Map
development, which is the reason
why we have Brendan on
the show this week.
BRENDAN KENNY: I really
like the dev tools.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah and I've
learned a lot of things about
dev tools for Brendan myself.
So still getting warmed up
to the debugger myself.
But a lot of other techniques
that I use specifically for
tweaking visualization.
And so we're going to cover
those a little bit later.
And then Brendan is going to
cover some more of the getting
the map in the appropriate--
BRENDAN KENNY: --state that
you want it to be in.
PAUL SAXMAN: Perfect.
So with that I'll hand
off to Brendan to
show us the real stuff.
BRENDAN KENNY: Sure.
So I am a big fan of the Chrome
dev tools, but I'll
just note at the start that a
lot of the stuff that I'm
going to show here, you can do
in all the other browser
developer tools to
some extent.
There's always a trade off
between what you can do but a
lot of the major things, they
are all pretty similar.
But we're going to be showing
Chrome dev tools today because
they're really good.
So what we have here
is a Google Map.
And this is just a direct copy
of the map, simple example
that's in the Maps
API v3 example.
It's basically the simplest
map that you can throw
together that just has a div
here, a map campus div, and
throws a map in it
and that's it.
And we're just going to start
with this to take a look at
what we can do.
So if you've never opened up the
dev tools, you should, and
just get comfortable with it.
I've met a lot of developers
that just feel slightly
uncomfortable getting
to know it.
It's a new tool.
They might not know it that
well, and so when they open it
up it's like there's too many
options and it's all cluttered
and whatever.
It's intimidating.
And a lot of getting over that
is just using it a lot.
So to start up you come up to
the options and down to tools
and open up the developer
tools.
PAUL SAXMAN: Or you can remember
that extremely--
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, this alien
language, which is just
Command-Shift-I on the Mac and
then Control-Shift-I on--
that's not right.
What is it?
PAUL SAXMAN: I think
it's Left-Shift.
BRENDAN KENNY: It's Option.
That's what it is.
So it's Command-Option-I
and I guess
Control-Alt-I on Windows.
I don't know.
It's muscle memory.
It's in your settings.
So when it opens up, you know
down here it starts in the
elements view and it shows a
live view of the DOM of your
page and CSS on the right.
I don't think we're going
to be doing too
much in here today.
But it's a good place to start,
especially if you're
going back and look at our
earlier Maps API garages, you
can see we gave some tips
for like, my Map is not
showing up at all.
A good place to start
is on this screen.
PAUL SAXMAN: And a quick note
about the DOM is that that's
the effective DOM, right?
BRENDAN KENNY: Yes.
PAUL SAXMAN: So it's after
any DOM transferring--
BRENDAN KENNY: This is the
actual document tree that's
live in your document.
It might not actually match your
HTML if you've done some
transformation JavaScript, or
if you've just done bad HTML
that's not actually valid.
The browser will try
and fix it up.
And so it might insert elements
where you don't
expect them.
So one thing you can see here
is that all these wider
screens that are really popular
today, there's not a
whole lot of room for your
dev tools to also be
able to see the map.
And there is a handy option
used to be kind of buried
away, but now is pretty readily
available up front.
If you come down to the bottom
left you can see the undock
button, which lets you undock
it and have it as
a standalone thing.
But you're still managing it,
its place and everything.
But there is a very nice new
button that just lets you dock
it to the right.
And that's really handy on these
wider screens, as I say.
The DOM tree gets a
little awkward.
But it's useful for our
other panels here.
So I wanted to start and come
over to the developer console.
So this is a live JavaScript
environment that lets you
actually interact with
the page and anything
that's in the page.
So if you look at the Map simple
example, one of the
things that it does, which is
one of the most helpful things
you can do, is it leaves the map
object at the top level in
the global scope.
And that lets you actually
interact with it on the
JavaScript console.
When you go in to production
maybe you don't want to have
that exposed or you don't
want to pollute the
name space or whatever.
But during development it's
extremely helpful be able to
go in and actually tweak it.
So the example I like to give to
just start off here is the
classic example of I just want
to drop a Map in a page and
have it positioned to view
that looks good.
And so what you can do
if we go back over
to our source code--
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, quick, point
out the Map in the global
scope, what that looks like.
BRENDAN KENNY: Oh, here?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, not too
familiar with scope.
BRENDAN KENNY: So, yeah, you put
it here at the top scope
you declare your map.
And this makes it a
global variable.
Sometimes in examples you'll see
the Map is actually with
it, declared within the
initialized function.
And because you're actually
adding it to the DOM, it won't
be garbage collected even though
you no longer have it
referenced it to that variable
if you've only declared it
inside that function.
So the Map will go on living
like some kind of zombie, but
you'll have no way to actually
go in there and tweak its need
for brains.
I don't think that
metaphor works.
But so here's a pretty typical
way of declaring a Map.
You declare your Map
options object.
You then pass it to the Google
Maps instructor, along with a
reference to the HTML element
that you want
to put the Map into.
And so what you typically are
going to want to have, or what
you need, is actually a zoom
level to start off and a
lat-long center of your Map.
And so what you can do is sit
here and tweak these values,
like, OK, well I know that
North American is in the
Western Hemisphere and like,
whatever, California is on the
left side of the US.
And tweak these values and save
it and then flip back to
your Map and refresh.
But that's a little bit silly
because we can actually
interact with this Map life.
So if I go here into the
developer console and type
map, I actually get
this reference.
And it's been closure
compiled, so
everything's been minified.
You got all these short names
and sometimes it's a little
bit intimidating.
But if you go to the Maps API
docs, you can see all the
public functions or methods that
live on the Map object.
And you can also see some
of them in here.
So one thing you can do is say
map.getZoom and actually see
the current zoom of the Map.
And it's eight, which is exactly
where we started.
So let's say we do want
to go back here.
We zoom out and we do want to
start on California just
because
PAUL SAXMAN: That's
where we live.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, we're so
California-centric, I guess.
So we'll come down here and then
I really want to look at
the Moffett Airfield and
I want that to be the
center of my Map.
So I now have positioned this
and I think this a good view.
This is where I want to be.
So I can do map.getZoom to see
what I've done rather than
keep track of what zoom level
I'm on, or whatever.
And I can see that I'm
on Map zoom level 14.
And now I want to actually--
well, I'll go over here and edit
it and make this 14 so I
don't forget.
OK.
So now I switch back and now I
actually want the center of my
new map to be this as well.
So I can actually say
map.getCenter, but one thing
you'll see is that you get
this object back because
getCenter return is
a lat-long object.
And you can see there's really
nice variable names here,
which is actually great because
it keeps JavaScript
sights low, but it hides
it from you.
But you can do a really nice
thing that it has on it.
Getcenter.toString is overridden
by the lat long
object to give you a nicely
formatted lat long string of
your object.
And now I can just copy that
directly and let's keep all
the digits just for fun.
I left an extra thing
in there.
PAUL SAXMAN: There's
a lot of digits.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah.
So now when I save and I come
back over here and I'll zoom
out and move the map just so
you believe me, now when I
save and refresh, I start
exactly on Moffett field at
the center.
So it's really simple.
And if I'm boring you right
now, I apologize.
But this is a really good way
to just make this sort of
thing really easy.
And that's kind of the thread
throughout all the tips that
we're going to show
you today--
is just that there's lots of
ways you can interact with
your Map right in the developer
console so that you
can sit there and live tweak
it, rather than have to sit
there and edit, refresh,
edit, refresh.
And you lose the continuity
between the tweaks that you're
making and the code that you're
actually adjusting.
So I think I'm going to
show a few more things
that you can tweak.
OK.
So just as a Pro-tip, just
like most terminals or
consoles, you can hit
the Up-Arrow to
get your last entry.
So if I hit the Up-Arrow, I can
see the last entry that I
actually input as input.
And so that's going to be really
helpful for us if we
want to go back to a thing, like
if we messed something
up, we can go back
and check it.
PAUL SAXMAN: Some map options.
BRENDAN KENNY: Sure.
So the Map object, if we go back
to the constructor here,
the map object is constructed
with this map options object.
So we create this object literal
here, this far Map
options, and we add all these
properties to it, and then we
pass that to Map.
And the Map is constructed
with those options.
So that's fine.
But the Map object actually
can take Map
options at any time.
You can set options and pass
it a whole object full of
properties.
So you don't have to set things
individually if you
don't want to.
If you want to change your map
completely at the push of a
button, you can.
So let's take a look at that.
If I come back over here
and actually make--
I copied this Map options
directly from our source code
and I make this--
PAUL SAXMAN: Make
it look nice.
BRENDAN KENNY: --all
over again.
So now I can make this object.
And let's call it
something else.
Let's say, new options.
And now if I actually check, I
actually created a variable
called new options and I can
inspect it live and see the
center object and
what have you.
So if I go back up and hit
the Up-Arrow twice,
I can adjust this.
So let's say I really want a
zoom level 12 and I want my
lat long to become just
a nicer formatted one.
And now you get some benefits
like you'll start getting
completion by the dev tools.
And so I can actually see when
I hit map type ID dot, I can
see the options that
are available.
And in this case let's
switch to satellite.
And if I hit Shift-Enter, that
gives me a line break rather
than entering the console,
which is handy.
So now I have a new
options object.
And if I check the new options
object, it's there.
So what I want to do is actually
take these options
and add it to the Map.
And so I can do map.setOptions
new options.
When I hit Enter it switches
to a totally new place and
this looks like Santa Cruz?
Something like that.
PAUL SAXMAN: Right.
BRENDAN KENNY: And it switched
to the satellite maps.
And so if I want to switch back,
I can just set my new
options back to the original
thing and then set
map.setOptions and switch it
back to my Moffett field.
So that's really handy.
So what that means is that you
can actually sit there and
tweak all the options
right there live.
So this is even handier than
tweaking something and then
refreshing the page even within
the console because a
lot of these options can be
tweaked right at run time.
So I can go down here and
hit Clear to clear out
this mess or Clear.
PAUL SAXMAN: Show the zoom.
Like the min and max zoom.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah,
that's a good idea.
PAUL SAXMAN: That's
a really neat one.
So when you're passing in these
options objects, you're
only overwriting the ones
that you specify.
So, for example, like--
well I mean, default UI
is on by default--
but, for example, if he didn't
specify roadmap and he just
set a new lat long center then
it would still stay in the
roadmap mode but just re-specify
the center.
So you can--
BRENDAN KENNY: Right.
So if I do this different zoom
and center but I remove the
satellite, it will move these
to Santa Cruz but not switch
to the satellite view.
Because if you don't set a new
option, it doesn't overwrite
what you had already set.
PAUL SAXMAN: So it is just kind
of useful for just trying
out different values.
A lot of times what I want to
do with my Math is, for me,
specifically, when I'm like
building visualization, I want
to turn off certain
UI controls.
Like I want to see what it looks
like without the D-pad
or without the Map satellite
selector, that type of thing.
And also, zoom levels are really
important, because with
certain visualizations the
visualization only works at a
certain zoom level.
Like if you're zoomed too
far in, then your
information is too dense.
If you're zoomed too far out,
then maybe your heat map is
not showing density properly.
So you can do things directly in
here, actually, to set your
min and max zoom.
So what I find is really cool
about this is actually just
the UI controls, dynamically.
So can you do that real quick?
BRENDAN KENNY: What's that?
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, just set
like a max zoom to--
BRENDAN KENNY: Sure.
So, let's see, how do I--
So what I'm going to do is
actually hit Shift- Enter, and
now I'm going to do it
right like this.
So I was going to combine the
two, but why not have it on
separate lines.
So that the console can actually
execute multiple
lines of JavaScript.
It will just execute the
whole chunk of it.
And so this is actually
two statements--
we declare an object and then
we set the options right in
one go so that I could sit here
and tweak it and not have
to hit Up and find set options
and what have you.
So, yes, I don't care about the
center and i don't care
about the satellite.
This time I want to
do the mid-zoom.
Is that what you want to try?
PAUL SAXMAN: Sure.
BRENDAN KENNY: So the mid-zoom
is, as you said, it sets the
limits on the zoom
that you can do.
It can be your visualization.
It could be like I want to
center on a place and I don't
want you to zoom out and see
the whole world repeating
because it's just a total
distraction, what have you.
So if we set the mid-zoom, let's
see, but we really want
to set the max-zoom right now.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, sure.
Do all.
BRENDAN KENNY: OK, so
that's a good point.
So let's say we want the
mid-zoom to be five and we
want the max-zoom to be 10.
Let's say that.
And currently we're
at 12, I think.
So when we set this option it
will actually zoom us out
because we were at 12 and
so we've now set a
maximum zoom at 10.
So it zoomed us out,
which is nice.
And you can now see that we
can't zoom any more and we
can't zoom past five.
So that's handy.
So, yeah, that's another
option that you can
sit here and tweak.
Now I've decided that
actually 10 is not
sufficient, let's do 12.
And so now I can actually
go in two more.
And, well, that's
not quite right.
Let's do 11.
Like that.
And I've also decided that the
default UI, which is one of
your favorite ones
to get rid of.
It's not really necessary
here.
I don't need a pan tool.
I'm not interested in Street
View because I need some heat
map over it.
And I don't want the satellite
option because
I want a heat map.
So I can add one more
option here and it's
disable default UI.
Is it capital UI?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
True
BRENDAN KENNY: Let's try that.
So there we go.
So now it's gotten rid of all
the controls and looks great.
So I want to add this
back to my code now.
Because if I refresh the
page it's all gone.
And I can always still hit Up
and I get back the last thing
I entered, but I want to
actually add this to my code.
And so it's actually
really simple.
All I'm going to do here
is copy the options.
I could copy the full object,
but I'm going to actually
integrate this into my Map
options object and just copy.
And now I need to do
some formatting.
And now if I come over here and
refresh the page, you can
see that I am centered at
Moffett field but I'm limited
to my zoom level and the
default UI is disabled.
PAUL SAXMAN: We lost
our zoom controls.
But you can add those back in.
I mean there's an option
for zoom controls.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, and you
can still do scrolling and
double-clicking.
So that's one way.
There's a couple
different ways.
So I have my new
options object.
And there's a couple different
ways to get it out.
Honestly, the easiest one
I find is just to
Copy and Paste it.
You can also do something
like, JSON did
stringify new options.
And this just uses the built in
JSON functionality to turn
your object into a string
so that you can copy it.
The problem is that you get all
these extra quotes and I
hate those.
But some people like those
and so if that's
your bag, that's great.
Or you can sit there
and delete those.
I personally prefer to
copy where possible.
And one final little pro-tip is
one of the other built in
functions that the dev tools
has is I can actually do
copyJSON.stringify
new options.
And that'll actually copy that
to the clipboard and if I came
over here and I could paste
it but then I'd
have to fix up whatever.
You can see that the outer ones
are at least disabled.
So this is at least actually
valid JavaScript, if you
consider those extra
quotes valid.
PAUL SAXMAN: It works.
BRENDAN KENNY: It
does execute.
That's true.
It's just ugly.
So I think that's all I'm going
to bore people with, and
if you want to show
even cooler things
that you can tweak.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
So my shtick is actually just
working on the visualizations
and trying to get the
visualization to look right in
the browser as well.
So this is a visualization
I've been working on.
So this is actually kind
of in debug mode.
We'll maybe talk about the
visualization itself at
another point, but essentially
it's just building heat maps
from images.
So what I want to do--
so I have a lot of
controls in here already.
These are custom controls
that I put in.
I actually did custom
styling as well.
So I'm going to go to someplace
interesting.
BRENDAN KENNY: Paris, Texas
is more interesting.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, there's
actually, unfortunately, not
enough photos.
I mean there's like 60
photos which are more
than I would've expected.
But so I just have some code
here that's actually just
going to build a heat map.
It's going to drop some polygons
onto the Map and then
do some scanning for
some photos.
BRENDAN KENNY: What is
the heat map doing?
What does it represent?
PAUL SAXMAN: This is actually
a density of photographs.
So I'm going to Picasa and
pulling down all the
photographs which include
lat-long information and then
building a heat map
out of that.
And this kind of sub-sectoring
thing--
we'll talk about this
at another point.
I don't want to bore people
about the unfinished business
of this visualization.
This sub-sectoring is actually
dealing with a cap on how many
photos you can pull down
and it's like 1,000.
So I keep zooming in to
different levels to pull more
information out.
Actually this was a bad place
because this just
has a ton of photos.
It takes a little
while to run.
So maybe we will go
to Paris, Texas.
Let me run this here.
And so in terms of dev tools,
there's a couple of things
that I want to do here.
So one is that I have
I heat map.
I may want to tweak, actually,
the styling of the heat map to
make it fit my presentation
a little bit better.
And the other is I actually have
a polygon on her that I
had put on earlier.
And I may actually want to
tweak the styling of the
polygon to make it fit a little
bit better with the
styling that I want.
So, again, I could go back to
my Sublime and actually edit
the code and then go back
over to reload the
page until I get that--
BRENDAN KENNY: --perfect
polygon styling?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, exactly.
So I'm really bad, like a lot
of times that I just want to
tweak the lightness by like one
or five or something like.
But you can do all this in the
Chrome tab tools like we were
showing earlier.
So one thing that's really
interesting, so what I did
with this visualization is
I have the polygon--
actually I have an array
of polygons that's
in the global scope.
I also have a heat map in
global scope as well.
So I can just go to the--
I have my heat map here and I
also have the polygons object
right here as well.
So I can just pull
these guys out.
I can see we only have one
polygon in here, actually
array nine.
Oh, it's because I'm
in the zero point.
And with that polygon I can
start doing things like set
some style options on here.
So this works exactly the
same way as the--
BRENDAN KENNY: You
missed the I.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, thank you.
It works the same way as
with the map object.
Whatever options you specify
when you created the object
are kind of the defaults at this
point and then you can
incrementally tweak them.
So what I want to do let's
say fill opacity 0.2.
Did that work?
Oh maybe I'm already at
0.2, let's do 0.8.
There we go.
So you can see that now, with
this polygon, I've actually
made it a lot more dense, or
the opacity a lot higher.
So things like you can do like
fill opacity, basically any
property on these.
Or you can do fill color,
for example.
Colors, since their hex, they
have to be in double quotes.
So if you have like complex
polygons, let's say even
polylines, markers, they work
the same way, just tweak these
in your browser.
Get them to the point that you
think they look right and then
just copy your values
back out again.
You can also do things like if
you want to get rid of it.
So I put this kind
of handy hide
polygons method over here.
It basically goes over my array
and deletes them all.
I could actually call that from
the console and actually
get rid of it.
Let's get it back again.
Or what I could do here
is I could just say
polygon0.setmap null.
And what setmap null, I mean
this works the same with
polygons, polylines--
and did I forget something?
BRENDAN KENNY: I'm like
a spell check.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
There you go.
BRENDAN KENNY: Right here.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
Now I have actually one more
in my collections.
BRENDAN KENNY: It'll
give you a clue.
Because it'll actually complete
as you go along.
It'll attempt to complete and
if it's not that means you
probably misspelled something.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
And the trick there
is just Tab.
As it starts to auto complete
you just Tab over
and it'll fill in.
Or you can Up-Arrow, Down-Arrow
to select if
there's multiple options.
So like I said before, so the
heat map is the same way.
So it actually works the
exact same way as well.
I do this quite a bit, actually,
because things like,
so radius and max intensity--
BRENDAN KENNY: Will
you zoom in?
So you can see it better?
PAUL SAXMAN: Zoom in.
Oh, well that's the trick.
BRENDAN KENNY: Oh, good point.
PAUL SAXMAN: So now what I can
do is if I decrease the
radius, that's going to actually
decrease the spread
of each data point.
So if I'm zoomed out too far
and I'm not getting a good
heat map, I can do things like
increase the radius to
actually make the data spread
out a little more.
The problem with that
is as I zoom in, the
radius stays constant.
So this could be a little bit
deceiving, as were talking
about earlier, it's like,
what is a heat map?
When the data, when you have
this actually spread, is it
actually error, or is it--
BRENDAN KENNY: It represents
some--
PAUL SAXMAN: --kind
of variance.
BRENDAN KENNY: --kind of area.
But often people don't actually
know what the area
represents.
So think about your heat maps
before you just make them
willy-nilly.
They look good though.
It's an easy way to make your
data look good though.
Just try not to lie.
PAUL SAXMAN: Totally.
Totally.
So, I mean, really good
at showing density.
So actually that's one point
about this heat map is I have
these points out here, you can
see kind of in the periphery.
Actually, that's only one
photograph and it's actually
showing some density
in my heat map.
I may not want that.
And the way that you can
actually tweak that is using
the max intensity.
So the next intensity specifies
the maximum density
that you'll actually show.
And then everything above
that is cut off.
So let's say for now, I think,
let's do something higher. as
I increase the max intensity,
you can see that actually the
lower density points actually
kind of fade off on the end.
So it's a nice trick if you
don't want to make the low
density areas prominent,
just keep
increasing your max intensity.
Likewise, the inverse
works as well.
So if you do actually really
want to show that there's some
activity in these low dense
areas you can actually
decrease the max intensity
to something really low.
But at that point there, when
you have max intensity of one,
that means every point,
actually, everything has the
same density.
See everything is actually
peaks at
red,which is not very useful.
BRENDAN KENNY: It might be.
You never know.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, maybe.
I guess it would be--
BRENDAN KENNY: You never know.
PAUL SAXMAN: So polygons,
polylines, you can style those
pretty simply.
Heat maps, you can actually
tweak those
dynamically as well.
If you want a marker on your
map, you can do things like
create these objects
on the fly.
I mean, you could even create a
heat map object on the fly.
If you're using MVC arrays for
your heat maps and your
polygons and your polylines,
actually you can dynamically
change your data.
I didn't really make an example
for that, but let's
say I wanted to plot another
heat map point on here, I
could actually go and I could
do it and add that to the
interface dynamically as well.
Markers, I mean, this is kind of
simple stuff, but you could
do things like this--
new google dot, so sometimes I
do this if I want to basically
am building an interface and I
want to actually see what it
looks like with certain
components on the Map, like a
polygons and markers.
You just add these things
dynamically.
Oops, I'm trying to talk and
think at the same time.
It doesn't always work
out very well.
But what is it?
So Map, and so you need
the Map for the--
So this is just going
to position a
marker on that for me.
And then another fun thing that
I like to do with this
for draggable true.
So this actually makes, now I
have to two, actually, because
I overrode that.
But you can just actually
add a draggable marker.
This is kind of fun too because,
like as Brendan
pointed out earlier, I can
actually go back to this
marker and actually get it's lat
long coordinates out if I
really wanted to.
BRENDAN KENNY: If you wanted
to set the exact right
position that you want
and copy back out.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, and actually
I used this when we
were doing the Mars map because,
on the Street View
imagery, they had named
the certain rocks.
But they didn't give
us the lat long
coordinates of the rocks.
So I actually had to take the
marker, make it draggable,
drop it on the rock, and then
get the coordinates back out
so I could actually position
it for the map.
BRENDAN KENNY: Luckily, since
then they've released the
exact position.
So we don't have to fake
it anymore or guess.
It wasn't a fake.
I mean is was as real
as we could get.
PAUL SAXMAN: Maybe we should go
back and see how accurate
our marker preposition was.
BRENDAN KENNY: That'd make for
a really interesting session.
PAUL SAXMAN: So one last thing
that I was going to do real
quick is Map style.
So a Map style is another
one that you can
actually tweak in here.
So it really helps.
So what we generally do with Map
styling is you definitely
want to use the [? styles ?]
maps wizard.
You use [? styles ?] maps wizard
to get pretty close to
what you want.
But then as you start layering
on a user interface--
or actually like your heat maps,
a lot of times your heat
map maybe isn't as intense as
you want, so you actually want
to decrease the saturation of
the Map to make the heat map
stick out a little more.
Or maybe your parks look
a little bit dark.
Again, you can do all your style
tweaking right in the
Chrome dev tools.
So with that, it's just styles
and you can pace
your object in there.
BRENDAN KENNY: You need
to put and object.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, yeah.
I need my object.
See I came from a world
of Eclipse where--
There you go.
So now I just actually set
the pre-existing style.
Let me just look at
parks for example.
If I go back over here, I could
just Up-Arrow and I can
say let's go to lightness.
So I have my parks and I
want it minus 20 now.
So you see that I've
set a new style.
The parks have actually
got a lot darker.
Again, the best way to actually
go back once you've
actually tweaked your
style to something
that you like we can--
oh, there we got that's got
a little color now--
the best way to get it back out
is just copy and paste.
Take this code, actually,
probably be even better to use
your technique, but just copy,
paste back out once you get
everything tweaked the
way you like it.
So the idea is that instead
of actually doing your
development in your text editing
tool, you actually
push a lot of the development in
to the browser so that you
can kind of view this
dynamically, make your tweaks
on the fly and save you a lot
of time from Alt-Tabbing or
whatever it is to go
between windows.
BRENDAN KENNY: And if you're
doing a lot of development you
can always make custom functions
explicitly for
development.
Things like set hue could be a
function that you write and
then it actually sets the hue on
like five different things
at once-- your markers, your
map style, or whatever.
It does all these
things at once.
And that way you can tweak it
until you have it right, maybe
pass it off to a designer who is
less interested in actually
poking around parts of your code
or something like that,
especially if it's kind of
spread out depending on your
development style.
And then once they have it
exactly where they want it,
you can then go in and copy
those values you generated
back in your source code.
And there's a couple different
ways you can do that.
Other than that, we're not
going to cover today.
But there's lots of information
available out there.
Lots of screen casts from
Paul Irish and the
Chrome dev RL team.
They do a really good GDL
on the dev tools.
Things like maybe it's not all
your code that you can really
just go in it and put things
in the global scope.
And so you can actually set
break points into styling
functions so that when it gets
there, you can tweak the
values live that are
going to get passed
into the Maps object.
Or you can actually make changes
to the source code in
the source panel and then save
it to a file on its own.
And that's all covered in those
videos and we might
cover in a future session.
But for now we'll leave
it at this.
This is something really
simple that you
can start with today.
If you've avoided using the dev
tools, you should open it
up and just start playing in
the console because it's a
dead simple thing.
There's almost no UI that you
need to learn compared to all
the ways to step through your
code or tweak your CSS.
And so it's a great way
to get started.
You'll soon find that it makes
your work flow so much better
and so much faster, especially
if you're using Alerts still.
And if you are, something's
wrong with you.
You shouldn't do that.
PAUL SAXMAN: I'm just getting
over console.log.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah.
Well console.log is useful.
That's a good thing.
Just don't alert.
PAUL SAXMAN: But I'll second the
point about checking out
some of the Chrome teams.
One we were going to show today
was like tweaking CSS
styles, they've covered that
ad nauseum, I think.
But like all these controls,
like when we build these kind
of map-centric interfaces and
we drop our own custom
controls, there's no reason you
can't tweak these things,
tweak the CSS and
export it out.
BRENDAN KENNY: It's
all in your DOM.
PAUL SAXMAN: Using some other
techniques that the Chrome
team covers.
So with that we will bid adieu
and if you guys have any
questions, just post them in the
comments and we'll try to
get back to you guys on those.
And hope you enjoyed the show.
See you in a week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]